>>> TONIGHT A RUSSIAN ACTOR IS
SPEAKI OUT AGAINST PUTIN'S
INVASION OF UKRAINE AND HER OWN
FAMOUS FATHER'S SUPPORT OF IT.
VLADIMIR IS A VERY FAMOUS ACTOR
AND SO THAT AT PUTIN'S RALLY A
FEW DAYS AGO.
YOU MAY RECOGNIZE HIM.
HE'S BEEN IN MANY MOVIES LIKE
MISSION IMPOSSIBLE, GHOST BROKE
WITH TOM CRUZ.
HERE'S PART OF WHAT EMAT THAT
PRO PUTIN RALLY.
>> Translator: LUCKY ARE THEY.
THOSE WHO SEEK TO BE POLITICALLY
CORRECT IN THE EYES OF EUROPE
AND AMERICA WALLOWING IN HATRED.
WE ARE RUSSIAN PEOPLE.
WE LOVE OUR COUNTRY.
WE ARE FOR THE WORLD WITHOUT
NAZIISM.
WOULD HAVE WE ARE FOR OUR ARMY,
FOR OUR PRESIDENT.
>> HIS DAUGHTER, AN ACTRESS WHO
HAS LIVED IN THE UNITED STATES
FOR SIX YEARS, OPPOSES THE WAR
AND SHE RESPONDED TO HER
FATHER'S SPEECH IN PART, QUOTE,
TODAY MY DAD SPOKE.
I REALLY WISH ALL HE HAD SAID
WAS TRUE.
THE SORT OF NEXT UNSAID WORDS
WERE, BUT IT IS NOT TRUE.
LET ME START WITH THIS QUESTION,
MASHA.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE TO SEE YOUR
FATHER STANDING THERE AND TO
HEAR HIM SPEAK LIKE THAT?
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW,
IT IS JUST UNTHINKABLE AND
SURREAL AND THE FACT SO MANY
RUSSIAN PEOPLE INCLUDING MY DAD
BELIEVE THAT THIS VIOLENCE IS
SOMEHOW JUSTIFIED.
IT BREAKS MY HEART.
IT IS NOTHING COMPARED TO THE
WHAT THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE NOW, DYING.
SEO SO MASHA, I WANT TO TALK TO
YOU ABOUT YOU AND YOUR FATHER.
YOU HAVE THIS PERSPECTIVE ON WHY
HE BELIEVES THIS.
EVERYONE WANTS TO UNDERSTAND.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT YOUR
FATHER AND OBVIOUSLY MILLIONS OF
OTHERS, MANY MILLIONS OF OTHERS
IN RUSSIA, BELIEVE WHAT HE IS
SAYING?
>> I DON'T WANT TO TALK FOR HIM.
I CAN TALK FOR MYSELF.
I JUST, I WAS PRIVILEGED TO
TRAVEL AROUND THE WORLD AND SEE
THE WORLD WITH MY OWN EYES.
I WORKED A LOT IN RUSSIA AND
UKRAINE, AND LESS THAN A YEAR
AGO, I WAS IN KYIV AND I SAW
BEAUTIFUL, KIND, UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE.
I HAVE MANY FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES THERE.
NONE OF THEM HATED ME FOR BEING
RUSSIAN.
AND NONE OF THEM ASKED TO BE
ATTACKED BY MR. PUTIN.
THAT'S WHAT I SAW.
>> SO WHAT DO YOU WANT RUSSIANS
WHO SUPPORT PUTIN ATTACKING
UKRAINE, WHAT DO YOU WANT THEM
TO KNOW?
>> I KNOW THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF RUSSIANS, MY FRIENDS, AND
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE IN ABSOLUTE
AGONY RIGHT NOW, SEEING
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE SUFFERING.
AND I JUST HOPE THAT WE CAN
SOMEDAY FIND FRIENDS TO
TRANSFORM RUSSIA INTO A COUNTRY
OF COMPASSION AND PROGRESS.
NOT LIES AND VIOLENCE.
I KNOW IT IS EASY FOR ME TO SAY
BECAUSE I'M IN ANOTHER COUNTRY
NOW AND I'M NOT SURE THAT I'LL
BE ABLE TO COME BACK.
>> YOU MENTIONED YOUR TIES TO
UKRAINE.
I KNOW THEY'RE DEEP.
YOU MADE MOVIES THERE.
YOUR HUSBAND IS HALF UKRAINIAN.
WHEN YOU STOP FOR A MOMENT AND
THINK, CAN YOU BELIEVE SO MANY
MILLIONS OF RUSSIANS TRULY DO
NOT KNOW WHAT IS HAPPENING?
WHAT WE ARE SEEING, THE REALITY
OF THIS HUMAN SUFFERING, THAT
BOOMED'S INVASION IS CAUSING
UKRAINIANS?
>> I TALKED ON THE PHONE WITH MY
DAD YESTERDAY.
AND NOW, I DO BELIEVE THAT,
UNFORTUNATELY, YES, I TOLD HIM
THAT I'M GOING TO SPEAK TO YOU
GUYS, TO CNN, AND ASKED IF I CAN
TELL WHAT HE TOLD ME.
AND HE SAID, YES.
AND SO I'M, HE ASKED ME TO COME
BACK TO RUSSIA IMMEDIATELY TO
TAKE MY DAUGHTERS WITH ME AND TO
BE A GOOD RUSSIAN.
TO ASK FOR FORGIVENESS FOR
BETRAYAL, AND TO BE WITH RUSSIAN
PEOPLE, WITH MY PEOPLE, TO HELP
FIGHT UKRAINIAN NAZIS.
>> OH.
I MEAN, MASHA, I UNDERSTAND,
YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO MAKE THE
POINT, RIGHT?
THAT WHAT YOU'RE GOING THROUGH
IS NOTHING IN COMPARISON TO
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN UKRAINIAN
BUT YOURS IS ANOTHER FAMILY NOW
BREAKING BECAUSE OF THIS.
IT HAS TO BE DIFFICULT, RIGHT?
YOU LOVE YOUR FATHER.
YOU CALL HIM TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION AND THAT'S THE
CONVERSATION.
THAT HAS TO BE REALLY HARD.
>> IT WAS VERY HARD DECISION.
BUT YOU KNOW, I'M NOT ONLY A
DAUGHTER.
I'M A MOTHER.
I HAVE TWO BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTERS.
DURING THE PANDEMIC, ONE OF MY
DAUGHTERS FOUND A DANCE TEACHER
ONLINE IN KYIV, OF ALL PLACES.
AND DURING THE WHOLE PANDEMIC,
THEY WERE DANCING FIVE OR SIX
TIMES A WEEK AND THEY BECAME
FRIENDS.
AND WHEN I WENT TO KYIV, I TOOK
HER WITH ME TO MEET HER BEST
FRIEND, HER TEACHER, DANIA, AND
WE HAD SUCH A GREAT TIME IN
KYIV.
SO PROBABLY BECAUSE OF THEIR
FRIENDSHIP I DECIDED TO SHARE MY
POSITION ON THIS WAR.
BECAUSE WHEN THE BOMBING
STARTED, MY DAUGHTER WAS
TERRIFIED.
AND WE WERE ON THE PHONE BACK
AND FORTH CONSTANTLY.
AND BECAUSE OF HER, I SPEAK NOW.
I KNOW WHAT IT MEANS THAT THE
BOMBS ARE FALLING.
AND BECAUSE OF WHAT IT WOULD
MEAN TO MY DAUGHTER LATER IN
LIFE.
>> AND DO YOU THINK, MASHA, DO
YOU WANT TO EVER GO BACK TO
RUSSIA?
>> I LOVE MY FATHER VERY MUCH.
HE IS ONE OF THE GREATEST ACTORS
LIVING TODAY.
AND I LOVE MY GRANDMOTHER.
MY MOM'S MOM WHO RAISED ME.
SHE IS IN RUSSIA NOW AND SHE
ALSO BELIEVES PUTIN'S VERSION OF
REALITY.
BUT I WAS ON RUSSIAN TV PROJECTS
AND RUSSIAN TV.
SO I AM PART OF THE SYSTEM.
MY GRANDMOTHER WAS WATCHING ME
IN THOSE TV SHOWS ABOUT A
DOCTOR, THIS A